listen you got to start with one if you  don't like something change it i think  that excuses are lies that we tell  ourselves convincingly but it really  starts with one it can be really  intimidating to look at the social media  feed and think that everybody ran a  marathon before 6 a.m and they all are a  five-minute mile you know what i mean  like ugh  that just made me feel  paralyzed with what i'm capable of yeah  so start with one literally start with  one like lace up do one block do one pal  town workout like do one  and  then that's what that's why i say that  confidence is a side effect of hustle  because when you take those little  nibbles of hustle you discover  that you really have the power all along  when you develop an appetite for your  own power  mediocrity doesn't taste so good anymore